[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
الثلوج تزيد من الضغوط على اوكرانيا
وروسيا تعيد ترتيب صفوفها وسط تاكيد على
ان اهداف العمليه ستتحقق
محافظو الوكاله الذريه يبحثون مشروع على
قرار يهدد باحاله ملف ايران لمجلس الامن
لعدم تعاونها مع تحقيق الوكاله
تجدد التضاهرات المطالبه بالحكم المدنيه
الكامل في السودان والامم المتحده تدعو
الجميع لتقديم تنازلات
الامير محمد بن سلمان يختتموا زيارته الى
سيول وزياره تنتج عن 25 عقدا استثماريا
بنحو 30 مليار دولار
قال لكريملين ان واشنطن قادره ان ارادت
على دفع كيف للدخول في مفاوضات اشار الى
انه في الوقت الحالي من الصعب تخيل الدخول
في مفاوضات عامه مع اوكرانيا كما تحدث ان
واشنطن قادره على اخذ المطالب الروسيه
بعين الاعتبار المتحدث باسم الكرملين
بمتري بسكوف اكد ان لا احد في روسيا يريد
استخدام السلاح النووي واضاف بان اهداف
العمليه العسكريه باوكرانيا ستتحقق عسكريا
او بالمفاوضات
وفي ظل هذه التطورات العسكريه هناك تساقط
اولي للثلوج الثلوج فصل الشتاء في الوقت
الذي تواجه فيه العاصمه الاوكرانيه انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي طبعا بسبب سلسله جديده
من الضربات الروسيه التي تستهدف البنا
التحتيه للطاقه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
هو في هذا السياقه فدا تقريرا لصحيفه
الفينا البريطانيه
كل من القوات الروسيه وايضا الاوكرانيه
طبعا يحسب خطواته المقبله بعد تراجع موسكو
من الضفه الغربيه لنهر دنيبرو وما تعتبره
كيف نصرا قد يصب في مصلحه الروس الذي
يعيدونها ترتيب صفوفهم ليش انه معركه
ضاريه تركز في الاتجاه الشرقي وايضا
الاتجاه الجنوب طبعا كل هذا وفق الصحيح
تنفذ خرسون دخان القنابل الروسيه عنها ليس
شرقا نهر النيبرو الذي يقسم اوكرانيا الى
جزئين وانما غربها الذي انسحبت منه موسكو
وعادت ادراجها الى الشرق لتعيد ترتيب
صفوفها
[موسيقى]
هنا في الضفه اليسرى يحتفل الاوكرانيون
ويمزقون كل حرفين يخص روسيا لكن في الضفه
المعاكسه لا يبدو المشهد مشابها فخريطه
المعركه التي باتت تراها كيف بعد الترجع
الروسي بدايه نهايه الحرب احدثت فرقا في
فتنه العسكريه للهجوم والدفاع وفق ما نشرت
صحيفه الفاينشل تايمز البريطانيه محللون
عسكريون توقعوا ان تشتد ساحه النزاع في
الاتجاه الشرقي من اوكرانيا اي ان نقاط
ساخنه ستتركز في اقليم تونس تحديدا
بالقرب من مدينتين بخموت وافديكا اما
البؤره الاخرى فقد تشهدوا قصفا مدفعيا
مكثفا في الجنوب باتجاه مدن بحر ازوف كم
مدينه
الاستراتيجيتين وبالفعل دوت صفارته
الانذار بعد استهداف الضربات الصاروخيه
الروسيه اقليم اوديسا ومدينه نيبولي اولي
مره من سريعه
وبحسب الخبراء فان هذا الانسحاب قد يشكل
نقطه قوه لكريم ليل لان القوات ستعزز
وجودها على طول خط الجبهه الشرقيه وعلى حد
قولهم فانه سيكون لي موسكو العدد الاكبر
من الجنود في كل كيلو متر مربع علما بان
ما يصل الى 50 بالمئه من الجنود سيعاد
نشرهم على مواقع دفاعيه
وبينما يخطط قاده الطرفين لاعاده التموضع
وتوزيع القوات ورسم خريطه المعركه فان
عوده الروس وفق الفينش التايمز قد تصب في
مصلحتهم رغم انهم رحلوا تاركين حزمه
عسكريه مهجوره في خرسون لكن اوكرانيا
تعتمد على عنصر المفاجاه وهمها في الوقت
الحالي ازاله الالغام التي خلفها الروسو
على ارضهم
اسراء الصغير العربيه
على كل المال المزيد معي هنا في الاستوديو
مراسل العربيه في روسيا الزاميلا عبد
الجواد الرشد اهلا بك عبد الجواد اسمح لنا
ابدا بالتصريحات الروسيه المتعلقه بتحقيق
الاهداف هل نحن نعلم ما هي الاهداف وهل هي
معلن الاهداف الروسيه في اوكرانيا الان
لانه بالبدايه كانت مختلفه تغيرت خلال
الوقت اليس كذلك
واصبحت تتحدث عن ان استهداف مراكز الطاقه
والاتصالات هو هدفها الاساسي هذا الشيء
يحدث طبعا قبل بدايه يعني فصل الشتاء
القاسي في تلك المناطق ثلوج قد تصل بدرجات
الحراره الى 20 درجه تحت السفر
المتعلقه
السياسيه
العمليه العسكريه خلال فصل الصيف تبحث عن
وجود حقيقي لها خلال فصل الشتاء باعتبار
ان عامل الثلج يعطيها دافع قوي في البدايه
طبعا الحديث يدور عن الجو المقاتلات
والطيارات والمروحيات هي قادره على على
العمل اكثر خلال فصل الشتاء باعتبار انها
مخفيه بعض الشيء بسبب الثلوج والامطار
والضباب والغيوم وغير ذلك
العسكريه الروسيه الثقيله لديها امداد
كبيره بما يخص قضيه الوقود بما يخصه
التجديد الاصلاح وغير ذلك على عكس الجانب
الاوكراني باعتبار انه موسكو تستهدف اليوم
معظم خزانات الطاقه التابعه للقطاع
العسكري ومنها خزانات الوقود الخاصه
والمختصه طبعا بقضيه المعدات العسكريه
والدبابات والمدرعات التي تدعم بجانب
المتوسط الغربي لاوكرانيا هل ستقف تنظر
الى الجانب الاوكراني يتقهقهر اذا ما صح
التعبير في فصل الشتاء طبعا موسكو من
الانسحابها الاخير كما سماه طبعا حسب
القراءه السياسيه هو انسحاب من تلك
المنطقه هو خساره لاراضي كانت موسكو قد
اعترفت بها بانها اراضي روسيه وخيرسون
جمهوريه واقليم من الاراضي الروسيه
الخريطه التي ترسمها موسكو اليوم لكن طبعا
الوضع العسكري ميسون على الارض يختلف كليا
عن الوضع السياسي اليوم اذكر تبحث عن عدم
فقدان عنصر الجندي لديها على ارض المعركه
وهذا ما دفع طبعا لنقل كميه كبيره قرابه
40,000 جندي طبعا القراءه العسكريه ترى في
ان هذا العدد كبير في ظل وجوده في تلك
المنطقه والمنطقه التي تفصله المسافه التي
تفصلها عن الجيش الاوكراني وصواريخ تقدر
بحوالي 30 كلم لذلك طبعا القراءه العسكريه
ترى في نقل هؤلاء الجنود هو يعني اقل
الخسائر بما يخص هذه القضيه بحيث انهم
الان يعني يصلون الى مسافه بعيده عن
النهار تقدر ب 70 او 80 كم وفي
خلال فصل الشتاء هذا ما تقوله
الصواريخ الاوكرانيه تلك المناطق باعتبار
ان منظمات الدفاع الجوي تحتاج لمسافه 70
او 80 كيلو متر لاسقاط الصواريخ مصر قامت
بتفجير الجسور على نهر النيبر حتى لا
يتمكن الاكران من عبورها والسيطره على
مناطق جديده والس- والسبيل الوحيد لهم
للوصول الى المنطقه الجنوبيه هو العبارات
ستهدفه ستستهدفها طبعا المدفعيه الروسيه
كما يدور الحديث في ظل طبعا الصواريخ
الروسيه التي تستهدف تلك المنطقه وقد تلحق
اضرار كبيره خاصه مع حلول فصل الشتاء
يعني السؤال التي سالته جزء من الاجابه
فيما يتعلق بقرصون كونه اراضي روسيه ولم
تعد كذلك هل لا زالت هذه همم الخطه قائمه
على اساس انه بغض النظر عن التطورات
الحاليه الان في النهايه هناك عوده
انه من يضحك اخيرا يضحك كثيرا هذا ما
يتحدث عنه الروس اليوم هو انسحاب تكتيكيكي
كما يرون في الموضوع لكن طبعا على ارض
الواقع الجميع بانتظار ام المعارف قد تكون
خيرسون معركه استهزاف بالنسبه للرؤوس هذا
ما يراهم بعض
محللين بما يخص طبعا القراءه الغربيه
للقصه لكن على الجانب الروسي هي معركه
حقيقيه ذاهبون نحو اعاده خيرسون يرون في
هذا الانسحاب هو تكتيك نوعا ما لكن طبعا
على ارض الواقع الوضع يجري بموضوع اكثر
خاصه ان التعبئه الجزئيه ميسون كميه كبيره
منها انتقلت الى تلك المناطق وخساره
الجنود قد طبعا تدعوا او تؤدي بالامر الى
استياء كبير داخل المجتمع موجوده
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه الاضافات بالنسبه
لنا وهذا الشرح كنت معنا في الاستديو
طبعا ليس بعيدا عن هذه التطورات لا تزال
قضيه الصاروخ الذي سقط في بولندا تتفاعل
فقد شكك رئيس الامريكي جوبيدا في تصريحات
الرئيس الاوكراني نيفلودو مارسيلنسكي الذي
نفى في وقت سابق ان يكون الصاروخ الذي سقط
في هولندا اوكرانيا قال بيدن للصحفيين
البيت الابيض لدى عودته من اسيا انه لا
دليل على ان نفيزلنسكي ليس دليلا وان كل
المؤشرات تؤكد انه صاروخ اوكراني وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن كان اكد من
جهته ايضا ان صاروخا اعتراضيه اوكرانيا
للدفاع الجوي كان على الارجح سبب الانفجار
مندوب روسيا الدائم لدى الامم المتحده
فسيله نفيدنسيا قال ان اوكرانيا وبولندا
حاولت اثاره الصدام المباشر بين روسيا
والنيترو
نيمورك
رئيس مكتب الامن الوطني البولندي قال من
جهته ان اوكرانيا ستتمكن على الارجح من
الوصول الى موقع الانفجار في جنوب شرق
بولندا رئيس البولندي كان ذكر في وقت سابق
ان الوصول الى موقع الانفجار يتطلب موافقه
البلدين لدين يقودان التحقيق وهنا نتحدث
عن بولندا والولايات المتحده
فيديو
[موسيقى]
اكس بوكس
استراليا امريكا
المزيد معنا من بروكسل الدكتور رمضان ابو
جزر مدير مركز بروكس للدوله للبحوث اهلا
بك دكتور رمضان يسمح لي انا ابدا بقراءه
للمواقف الان ان كان في ما يتعلق
بالولايات المتحده او حتى اوكرانيا على
كافه الاصعده هل ترى ان هناك مواقف واضحه
وصريحه لا زالت قائمه على الاسس التي بدات
فيها في دعم الولايات المتحده لاوكرانيا
او تلاحظ انه في تغير بهذا الاطار
مساء الخير بالعكس هناك
حظنا تراجع عن في حده الخطاب الامريكي
وهمم كان هناك خطابا همم ايجابيا متبادلا
بين الطرف الروسي والامريكي في قمه ال 20
يبدو ان هناك توافقا امريكيا صينيا همم
لانهاء هذه الحرب وهذا همم
ظهر جليا في بعض المعلومات التي رشحت عن
بدء الاجتماعات الروسيه الامريكيه بمعزل
عن الطرف الاوكراني و الاوروبي همم ايضا
همم رد الروسي على التقرير الامريكي او
على الاعلان الامريكي بان روسيا غير
مسؤوله عن الصواريخ التي سقطت في الحدود
البولنديه همم وتسمين روسيا للموقف
الامريكي والحكمه الامريكيه في التعامل مع
الازمه المفتعله لمده همم ساعات همم كان
ردا ايجابيا ويمهد لاجواء عوده للتفاوض
الدكتور رمضان باي اثاره او تحت اي مظله
لانه الجانب الروسي ايضا قال انه من الصعب
الان تخيل مفاوضات عامه شو يعني عامه مع
اوكرانيا
الذي كان خارج اطار ما همم تحدث به
الامريكان والصينيين همم جيلنسكي حاول ان
يصعد عندما استشعر اا زينسكي وحتى بولندا
استشعر ان امكانيه هناك تهدئه في الاجواء
بين روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بدا التصعيد بشكل خطير لدفع همم الامور
الى منحه خطير مجددا وكان هناك اشتراطات
على لسان الرئيس زينكي كثيره جدا في قمه
العشرين يصعب على الطرف الروسي تقبلها
كبدايه للمفاوضات لذلك كان الحديث رد
الروسي لن يكون هناك بدء مفاوضات بشكل عام
الشكل العام اي هناك شروط اكثر من 20 شرط
طرحها زينسكي يرفضها الروس كقاعده للبدء
المفاوضات ولكنهم يدعون في اوكرانيا
للمفاوضات حادثه الصاروخين ابدت همم مد
التضامن الاوروبي وتضامن حلف الناتو مع
بولندا وهي رساله الى روسيا بان الحلف
الناتو مستعد همم لحمايه كل الدول الاعضاء
واعطت رساله تضمين ورساله التضامن الى
بولندا ولكنها لم تعطي لاوكرانيا ما تريده
وهي جرح حلف الناتو والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى مواجهه عسكريه مباشره
في ما يتعلق بانه القرار بالنهايه هو قرار
امريكي والولايات المتحده قادره على الضغط
على اوكرانيا همم بدء التفاوض هل هذا
بالفعل صحيح ام انه نرى بانه ممكن ان
ينتفض زينسكي على قرارات الولايات المتحده
لدرجه كبيره هذا الحائط صحيح جدا لان
الولايات المتحده هي صاحبه الرياضه وصاحبه
القرار في فيما يتعلق بالدعم العسكري
الكبير والدعم هو حتى الدعم الذي يقدمه
حلف الناتو وهو دعم مهم جدا بالمناسبه وهو
الذي غير خريطه همم مجرى المعارك على
الاراضي هو الدعم الذي قدمته الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ودول الحلف
بضغط من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن
هناك جهات يعتبر طرف ثالث وهو طرف خطير
جدا ويمكن ان يؤثر على مجرى الاحداث هناك
طرف خطير جدا اوكراني بولندي لاتفي خبراء
من دول ليس لديها مصلحه هذه الحرب يحاول
ان يعمق او يطيل زمن هذه الحرب الحديث عن
من هي الجهه المسؤوله عن تفجير همم خطوط
الغاز من هي الجهه التي حاولت ان همم ترثق
تهمه اطلاق الصواريخ او سقوط الصواريخ
الاوكرانيه التي سقطت على الاراضي
البولنديه بانها صواريخ روسيه من هو الجهه
التي دفعت 70 ردود فعل همم
سريعه جدا وطلب اجتماع همم لحلف الناتو
ومحاوله استجلاب او تفعيل الماده الرابعه
والماده الخامسه وكانها تبحث همم جر
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الدكتور رمضان
وبالتالي السؤال هل هذه الاطراف الثالثه
اذا ما صح التعبير كما سميتها انت قادره
على تغيير المسار اذا ما قررت الولايات
المتحده همم وقف هذه الحرب او هذه
العمليات العسكريه والتفاوض بدء التفاوض
مع روسيا
لقد فشلت هذه الاطراف الطرف الثالث في هذه
المره ولكنهم سوف يستمرون في المحاولات
للاسف الروسيا احيانا تعطي فرص للطرف
الثالث الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
ليست بريئه من بدء او اطاله عمر هذه الحرب
ولكن استشعرنا او نسجل في الايام الاخيره
الماضيه ان هناك رغبه امريكيه في العمل
على وقف هذه الحرب همم هذا الامر لم يكن م
م م م لم يكن هو ذاته في الاشهر او في في
الاشهر الماضيه كانت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي المحرض على استمرار هذه
الحرب ولكن يبدو ان هناك صفقات لم يتم
الاعلان عنها قد تمت
عن سيناريوهات لاخراج اتفاق يرضي جميع
الاطراف ومن غير من غير المامون ان يكون
مرضيا لاوكرانيا بالذات للدكتور رمضان ابو
جزر مدير مركز بروكس الدولي للبحوث شكرا
جزيلا لك
الامين العام للامم المتحده عن التوصل الى
اتفاق لتمديد اتفاق الحبوب في البحر
الاسود مشددا على تجاوز العقبات التي قد
تعترض تنفيذ الاتفاقيه
تركيا
توصلت تركيا واوكرانيا وروسيا والامم
المتحده الى اتفاق بشان تمديد مبادره
الحبوب في البحر الاسود ما يسمح بالتصدير
الحر للحبوب الاوكرانيه الامم المتحده
ملتزمه ببذل كل جهدها لتنفيذ الاتفاقيه في
اسطنبول من قبل مركز التنسيق المشترك
وتجاوز العقبات امام الصادرات المعطله
لتجنب ازمه الغذاء
في الخامسه ولكن بعد
قليل رئيس الوزراء العراقي في مديره عام
الطيران المدني ومديره مطار بغداد من
مهامهما شو بحرقين في غضون يومين
في بلدنا فيها شيء ميزها يا سيدي على لمه
اهل الحجاز لقمه منته على صفاتهم ولا
الحنين تحت غيوم الجنوب وسط جبالها والله
على صحن جريش يجمعنا في نجد الاحباب
[موسيقى]
على بحر الشرقيه
وبهارات ثري دي يا بعد حيي ماخذه من ريح
الهبوب الشماليه ولبن المراعي طعم المميز
حاضر معنا فيكي جمعه الحلوه
ايران في لبنان
بصفتك انت كنت كابتن طيار خلينا نقول انت
الي حتقود الرحله اليوم بس تعاد شويه شويه
من المطبات
ويطلع من النيل
لا اطالب بها وانما اكرس قيمتها عندك
حصيله لغويه او قدره لغويه كبيره الان
تستطيع من خلالها تفسير القران
تجريما دوليه سؤال مباشر مع خالد الجمعه
الخامسه والنصف على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه يبحث مجلس
المحافظين التابع للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه مناقشه مشروع قرار اوروبي امريكي
جديد ضد ايران
بمواقعها النوويه السريه مصادر
الدبلوماسيه اكدت للعربيه ان مشروع القرار
الغربي حول ايران يحظى باجماع كبير وسيتم
تبنيه باغلبيه كبيره اشارت مصادر
الدبلوماسيه للعربيه الى ان اللهجه البيان
اقصى من القرار السابق في يونيو يحمل
تلميحا الى امكانيه حاله ملف ايران الى
مجلس الامن في حال استمرارها بعدم التعاون
كان مدير الوكاله رافاييل جراسي قد قال
امس انه لا يجوز ان يبقى التحقيق في اثار
اليورانيوم سريه مفتوحه للابد من دون
الحصول على جواب في ما حضر سفيره الاتحاد
الاوروبي حضر ايران من ان عدم تعاونها
السريع مع الوكاله سيؤدي الى تصعيد اكبر
وان الدول الغربيه ستناقشه خطواتها
المقبله حال لم تبدي ايران تعاونا سريعا
قال لا دبلوماسيه اوروبيه للعربيه ان لدى
الدول الغربيه خيارات كثيره يمكنها اللجوء
اليها في حال لم تتعاون ايران بشكل سريع
الاتحاد الاوروبي من جانبه اتهم ايران
بانها لم تتخذ بعد الاجراءات اللازمه في
ما يتعلق بالقضايا العالقه في ملف
الضمانات النوويه قالت بعثه الاتحاد
الاوروبي امام مجلس محافظي الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في فينا ان طهران
لم تقدم تفسيرات ذات مصداقيه فنيه بشان
الضمانات واشارت الى المخاوف الجده بشان
وجود مواد نوويه في مواقع غير معلنه في
ايران البعثه الاوروبيه اعربت عن القلق
البالغ من ان الموقع الحالي لهذه المواد
النوويه غير معروف للوكلات الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه
المزيد معنا من فينا مفردات العربيه الى
هناك راغده بهنام اهلا بك ماذا لدينا من
معلومات حول مشروع القرار هذا اين وصلنا
راغده
مرحبا ميسون يعني كان هناك استراحه ظهرا
يعني لمجلس المحافظين ومن المفترضين مقابل
دقائق من الان عاده المجتمعون الى داخل
القاعه وكما فهمت سيطرح مشروع القرار يعني
فورا اعادت عوده انعقاد هذا المجلس يعني
في اي لحظه يمكن ان يتم التصويت على هذا
القرار ايضا كما فهمت من اكثر
دبلوماسيه تحدثت اليه بانه همم هناك عدد
كبير من الدول داخل مجلس المحافظين ستصوت
لصالح المشروع او بانه الغربيه مرتاحه لان
هذا المشروع سيتم تمريره همم بسهوله
باغلبيه كبيره ليست هناك مخاوف يعني من
عرقلته همم السؤال اهم ما هو سيكون رد فعل
ايران هناك ترقق كبير ليرتفع لايران همم
دبلوماسي اوروبي ايضا كنت اتحدث معه
وسالته ما اذا كان هناك مخاوف من ان تعقد
يعني يعقد هذا القرار الجديد المرتقب
العلاقه اكثر مع ايران قال بانه الوضع
الان سيء جدا بمعنى الى اي مدى يمكن ان
اكثر ااا يعني يبدو بانه ليست هناك مخاوف
لدى هذه الدول الغربيه التي طرحت المشروع
من ان يؤدي هذا القرار يعني عندما يتم
تبنيه الى يعني تعقيد لوضع اكثر لانه هي
هي تعتقد ان الوضع سيء جدا ويعني هكذا
قرار لا يمكن ان يعقد الوضع اكثر مما هو
معقد اصلا
ليس هناك من ردود فعل او تصريحات همم
ايرانيه في هذا الاطار وبالمقابل ان لم
يكن هناك من خوف من خلال اتخاذ هذا القرار
من قبل هذه الدول ماذا عن ايران لماذا
ستتخوف لانه بحسب ما افهم اذا ما حول الى
مجلس الامن فهناك روسيا والصين لدعممها
يعني الان ما زال ربما الحديث يعني مبكر
قليلا للحديث عن حاله المجلس الامن لانه
سيكون هناك اشهر بضعه اشهر ثلاثه اربعه
ربما سته اشهر امام ايران يعني ربما قبل
ان يتم احالتها او تبحث هذه الدول جديه
باحالتها الى مجلس الامن يعني هناك تلويح
في هذا القرار كما فهمت في هذا المشروع
انه هذه امكانيه ولكن ليس هناك قرار متحد
بتوقيع هذا بتوقيت هذا الامر حالات المجلس
الامن بالفعل يمكن ان يصطدم بعرقله روسيا
ولكن يمكن ايضا ان يعود اذا ما تم دمجه مع
مساله اتفاق النووي يمكن ان يعود ان يعيد
همم بنقطه سناب يمكن ان يعيد على العقوبات
فورا على ايران او يمكن ان يعني يحصل
البحث عن ذلك في مجلس الامن ويخرج من سلطه
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه هنا
هي تعتبر خطوه تصاعديه حتى ولو اصطدميه
يعني لا حقا بعرق على روسيه هناك ولكن
تعتبر تصعيد بانه هذا الملف عادي الى مجلس
الامن الاولى منذ ان عادت ايران التعاون
يعني وبدات المفاوضات التي ادت لاتفاق
العام 2015 الرد الفعل الايراني سنسمعه من
دون شك بعد ان يصدر هذا يعني التصويت
والقرار ولكن يوم امس او قبل او اول امس
كان هناك كلام لمحمد اسلامي رئيس الوكاله
الذريه الايرانيه قالوا انه يعني اشعاري
لانه الاتفاق مع الوكاله قبل اسبوع على ان
تكون هناك زياره لي الوكاله اللي طهران
للبحث هذه المساله تحديدا لبحث مساله همم
اثار اليورانيوم التي عثر عليها في اماكن
سريه قد لا تحصل همم لذلك ننتظر وتنتظر
وكاله ايضا كما قال روسي امس ما اذا كانت
ايران سترغي هذه الزياره امام انها ستعود
وتلتزم بها
يعني تعتبرها الوكاله مقبوله
العربيه الى هناك شكرا جزيلا لك
وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين الامير عبد
اللهيان اتهم اسرائيل واتهما الدول
الغربيه بوضع مخططات لتقسيم ايران وزير
الخارجيه غرد عبرات وتر قائلا ان الاجهزه
الامنيه والاستخباراتيه يحاولون تفكيك
ايران وتدميرها مؤكدا ان ايران ليست ليبيا
او السودان وانها لن تقبل بهذه المخططات
[تصفيق]
طبعا هذا وقد تواصلت الاحتجاجات في مناطق
متفرقه من ايران وسطه هتافات معاديه
للنظام وايضا لخاميه
في شيء جنازه
[موسيقى]
لا بابا اول شيء
هذا المشاهدين كما ذكرت مراسله العربيه في
اي لحظه يخرج القرار والتصويت على مشروع
القرار من محافظين الوكاله الريا وبالفعل
صوتوا على هذا القرار وفيه طبعا امر كما
جاءنا التصريح امر لايران بالتعاون فيما
يتعلق باثار الايرانيوم على كل المزيد
معنا من اصله عضو منظمه حقوق الانسان
الاحوازيه عمار كسائي اهلا بك سيد عمار
تعليق اولي على هذا القرار وماذا نتوقع من
رد فعل ايراني حوله
تحيه لك والمشاهد الكرام طبعا التصويت على
هذا القرار يعتبر خطوه مهمه اعتقد ان
اخيرا الاتحاد الاوروبي
والدول الغربيه توصلت الى هذه النقطه انها
لا يمكن ان
تستفيد من شيء اذا ما وصلت او تواصلت
بالليل مع ايران واعتقد الان النظام
الايراني هو في حاله ارتباك
بسبب الاحتجاجات وبسبب ما تشهده الساحه من
اضرابات والوضع الاقتصادي
المتردي اعتقد ان النظام الايراني
يتخذ خطوه باتجاه التصعيد الاكثر ربما
يحرك اذرعه بالخارج شو الاوراق التي يمكن
ان يستخدمها بهذا الاطار
الاوراق التي يمكن ان يستخدمه او سوف
يستخدمها بالتاكيد هي جميع الاوراق من
تحريك همم
الجهات التي ترتبط به وبالاضافه الى ربما
ياتي بالتقسيم باكثر ما هو الان اكثر من
60% ويقترب اكثر من همم من صنع القنبله
الذريه لانه الان النظام في حاله انفعال
كما اا تعلمين ويعلم المشاهدون الكرام ان
القضيه الاحتياجات هي اربكت النظام اربكت
خطابته حساباته تماما فهو اليوم يحاول باي
شكل من الاشكال يهدئ الداخل
ويحاول ان يبدو قويا من الخارج فاعتقد انه
سوف يتخذ مزيدا من التصعيد وهمم لن يتراجع
امام هذه القرار الذي سوف يعني ياتي بربما
عقوبات اكبر او قرارات اكثر قرارامه مع
النظام الايراني
الى اي حد تعتقد انه قادر على تطبيق هذه
التهدئه
واي معلومات جديده في ما يتعلق بالتحركات
على الارض
يعني تحركات على الارض الان الاعتصامات
موجوده الاحتجاجات لا زالت مستمره الشعوب
في ايران كلها غاضبه ولكن النظام هل يمكن
ان يستطيع على تهدئه والقضاء على الثوره
الموجوده لا اعتقد ذلك لانه الان هناك رفض
شعبي
والرفض ليس المطالبه باصلاحات ولا
المطالبه بتغيير وانما المطالبه بالاطاحه
والمطالبه
باسقاط النظام واحد الان بلغ عدد ضحايا
هذه الاحتجاجات
36 شخصا بينها هناك همم الاف في المعتقل
هناك عشرات او مئات الجرحى لا اعتقد ان
همم الشعوب الايرانيه تتراجع لانها وصلت
الى قناعه ان لها حياه لها الا باسقاط
النظام واستبداله بنظام اكثر الديمقراطيه
كم واا اكثر يناسب الوقت ويناس
على لسان الوزير قالت بانه هناك مخطط
لتفكيك ايران الى اي احد هذه المخاوف
حقيقيه وواقعيه ان كان من الخارج او في ظل
ما يحدث على الارض ام انها محاوله لاخافه
الناس وهل يمكن ان يكون لها تاثير عليهم
الانظمه الديكتاتوريه عندما تجد نفسها في
ضيق وعندما تتعالى الاحتجاجات دائما
تنسبها الى الخارج وخاصه بما ان الشعوب
الايرانيه والايرانيين لديهم قلق دائما من
تفكيك ايران ومحاوله الانفصال بعض الشعوب
من ايران فلذلك هذا النظام عده مرات كرر
هذه الادعاءات مره مره قال ان الاكراد
يريدون ان يقسمون ايران مره قال انه العرب
عايزين يريدون تفكير ايران ولكن هذه
اللاحه الحقيقه لها الشعوب الايرانيه هي
متماسكه في رفضها وفي رفضها لهذه النظام
جميعها من الذين يسكنها طهران
او شعوب مناطق غير الفارسيوم متفقون على
كلمه واحده وهي اسقاط النظام واحلال
النظام
ديمقراطي والحصول على الحقوق جميع هذه
الشعوب الموجوده في جغرافيه ايران وهذه
الاتهامات التهامات باطله يحاول النظام
يعني تشديد الانتباه من المظاهرات الشعبيه
الموجوده في الداخل عضو منظمه
حقوقيه عمار كسائي شكرا جزيلا لك
تجددت في الخرطوم التظاهرات التي تطالب
بحكم مدني كامل في السودان كما تاتي هذه
التظاهره في ذكرى احتجاجات السابع عشر من
نوفمبر التي قتل فيها 15 متظاهرا متابعه
[موسيقى]
كيف الحال
الله يديك العافيه
وفي المقابل قال مفاوض الامم المتحده
الحقوق الانسان والكرتون قال انه يجب على
جميع الاطراف العمليه السياسيه دعمها في
السودان وتقديم تنازلات وتغليب مصلحه
البلاد شدد ايضا على ضروره التوصل الى
توافق وطني الشامل يسهم في تحقيق مصلحه
السودان على المستويين المحلي وايضا
الدولي مشيرا الى انه يتضامن مع
السودانيين الذين يطالبون بتحقيق تطلعاتهم
نحو الوصول الى المستقبل
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه
محمد عثمان اهلا بك محمد انقل لنا المشهد
من عندك او حجم هذه التظاهرات والشعارات
الرئيسيه المرفوعه
هذا المشهد بدا منذ الساعه الواحده بتوقيت
الخرطوم حيث بعد تنسيقيات لجانا المقاومه
هنا في منطقه الخرطوم بحري الى هذه
التظاهره الى هذه النقطه تحديدا شارع
المؤسسه في منطقه الخرطوم بحري وفي ذلك
دلاله ورساله مهمه همم من تنسيقيات لجانا
المقاومه وهو احياء ذكرى مجزره السابع عشر
من نوفمبر هذا اليوم الذي له يعني دلاله
كبيره لدى المتظاهرين حيث يعني تم في هذا
اليوم يعني همم الاعتداء على المتظاهرين
مما ادى الى وفاه 15 من الشباب
والشابات في هذا اليوم ايضا كانوا همم
المتظاهرين كانوا قد دخلوا الى محيط القصر
الرئاسي وذلك في العام السابق وبالتالي
هذا اليوم له دلاله كبيره واهميه همم
كبيره الرساله اخرى التي فهمت من هذه
التظاهره اليوم انها الرساله ل- اا المكون
العسكري والمكون المدني همم هذه الرساله
هي تحمل الرفض اا تنسيقيات لجانا المقاومه
لما سمي
بالتفاهمات ما بين المكون العسكري والمجلس
المركزي لقوى الحريه والتغيير والتي تم
الاعلان عنها يعني في المؤتمر الصحفي مساء
الامس لجان المقاومه هي ما زالت تتمسك
بلائتها الثلاث لا تفاوض لا شراكه ولا
شرعيه وبالتالي هي ترى بان
التمسك بخيارات الشارع والتمسك ايضا
بانهاء ما سمي همم انقلاب الخامس والعشرين
من اكتوبر يجب ان يتم وفقه رؤيه لجان
المقاومه للعمليه السياسيه وليست رؤيه
المجلس المركزي لقوه الحريه والتغيير او
حتى المكونات المدنيه
لهم مرضا التصريح المتعلق بانه
توقيع اي اتفاق دون اشراق الجميع او لا
نعم هي تعتبر بان مساله تاجيل يعني كل
المطالبات التي دفع بها الشارع ودفعت بها
تنسيقيات لجانا المقاومه خاصه المتعلقه
باسر الضحايا المتعلقه بالانتهاكات التي
تمت للمتظاهرين في الشارع هم يعتبرون ان
تاجيل هذا الملف والملف المهم الى مرحله
التفاوض لاحقا يعتبر في حد ذاته خيانه
لخيارات الشارع وبالتالي يعني تنسيقيات
لجانا المقاومه هي تتمسك بكل المطالب التي
دفعت بها لكافه النخب السياسيه بضروره
انجاز ملف العداله والعداله الانتقاليه
وازاله ايضا اثار نظام البشير وكذلك عدد
من المطالب التي ما تزال متمسكه بها
تنسيقيات لجان المقاومه
حجم الاقبال همم طبيعه من لديه الكلمه
النهائيه بهذا الاطار او صعب تحديد ذلك
لانه في ذكرى ايضا اساسيه في هذه
التظاهرات وبالتالي لا يمكن لنا ان نفصل
من هو مع علاءات الثلاث ومن هو فقط موجود
لاحياء هذه الذكرى
نعم المجموعه التي دعت لهذه التظاهره
تحديدا هي مجموعه تتمسك باللائات الثلاث
ان لا تفاوض لا شراكه لا شرعيه ولكن ما
ذكرته صحيح ميسون باننا يعني بيتنا نشاهد
مشهد منقسم على نفسه بطبيعه الحال هنالك
تنسيقيات تتبع لجانا المقاومه هي منسوبه
لبعض الاحزاب السياسيه وهنالك من هو همم
غير محزب ولا ينتمي لاي حزب سياسي فقط
ينتمي للقضايا التي من اجلها خرج منذ يعني
2000 2018 ضد النظام المخلوع عمر البشير
وما زال متمسكا بكل هذه القضايا ما ذكرته
صحيح هنالك لجام مقاومه تتبع لاحزاب
سياسيه تنادي بمطالب محدده هي تدعم
بالمناسبه هذه التسويه وتقول ان فيها مخرج
الازمه السياسيه اما الجانب الاخر يرفض
تماما هذه همم التسويه يرفض
اللجوء همم لمساله الخيار مع الجلوس مع
المكون العسكري وبالتالي هو يرى في ان اا
قضاياه ومطالبه ما زالت لم تتحقق حتى الان
وهو من يتكفل وسينجز همم مساله تحقيق هذه
المطالب العربيه محمد عثمان شكرا جزيلا لك
اعفى رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني كل من مدير عام سلطه الطيران
المدني وايضا مدير مطار بغداد الدولي من
مهامهم اثرا نشوب حريقتين في غضون يومين
كانت قوات الدفاع المدني قد اخمدت حريقه
نشبت الثلاثاء داخل صلاه المغادره بمطار
بغداد الدولي دون التاثير على حركه
الطيران في حادث ذكرت وكاله الانباء
العراقيه انه اسفر عن اصابه ثلاثه عمال
باقتناق نتيجه كثافه الدخان
في الخامسه ولا كان بعد قليل
ارتفاع الملوحه في دلتا النيل نتيجه
استخدام الاسمده
ومبيدات الافات
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه زياره مليئه
بصفقات والاستثمارات يختتمها ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان الى كوريا
الجنوبيه 25 عقدا ومذكره تفاهم بقيمه 29
مليار دولار ابرمت بين السعوديه وكوريا
الجنوبيه في مختلفه المجالات الصناعيه
والاستثماريه خلال هذه الزياره شركه
ارامكم السعوديه اعلنت عن الاستثمار
الاكبر لها في كوريا الجنوبيه مشروع شاهين
من خلال شركه
التابعه لها وبقيمه تقدر بسبعه مليارات
دولار ولي العهد السعودي ذكر ان السعوديه
تتطلع الى رفع وتيره التنسيق الاستثماري
وتعزيز الشراكه بين القطاع العام والخاص
مع كوريا الجنوبيه وتحقيق الاستفاده
الكامله من الفرص التجاريه والاستثماريه
الواعده
تابع باهتمام كبير منجزات اللجان المشتركه
بين بلدينا وتطلع رفع وتيره التنسيق
الاستثماري وتعزيز الشراكه بالقطاعين
العام الخاص ونؤكد على اهميه الاستفاده من
فرص التجاريه واستثماريه الواعده والمتاحه
للتعاون بين بلدنا ونشيد هذا السياق
بالنمو الايجابي في السنوات الماضيه
للمعدلات التبادل التجاري بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وكوريا
[موسيقى]
من جانبه اكد وزير الاستثمار السعودي خالد
الفالح اكد على اهميه الشراكه بين المملكه
وكوريا الجنوبيه مشيرا الى انها تعد من
اهم الشركات على مستوى العالم
العلاقه بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه
من افضل الشركات على مستوى العالم اذا اذا
ممكن اقول فيها تكامل قويه المملكه لاعب
الدور كبير في نهضه كوريا الحديثه بعد
الحرب الكوريه في خمسينات القرن الماضي
من ناحيه توفير الطاقه اللي نهضت وساهمت
في النهضه الكوريه وفي نفس الوقت الكل
يعرف ان الشركات الكوريه اااه كان لها دور
كبير والموارد البشريه الكوريه كان لها
دور كبير في بناء البنيه التحتيه والشراكه
في بناء الاقتصاد السعودي الحديث
واعتبر الفالح ايضا ان شركه اس اويل تعد
من اهم استثمارات شركه ارامكو السعوديه في
الخارج مشيرا الى ان قيمه مشروع الشاهين
يصل الى 7 مليارات دولار
شركه ارامكو السعوديه خارج المملكه الان
بتنتقل من توفير الوقود والطاقه لكوريا
واسيا من خلال هذا الموقع الى بتسارع كثير
الى انتاج المواد البتروكيماويه وهو بيكون
في كراكر وبكون فيه صناعات متقدمه
للبتروكيماويات وبيكون في طبعا همم خفض
للكربون فهو يعني مشروع مثالي قيمته همم
يعني بين سته وسبعه مليار دولار واليوم
وقعترامكو عقود ال همم
الانشاء وانا اعتقد انه مشروع يستحق
الاشاده به
انتقدت الامين العامه لدول الكومنولث
باتري سياقات لندن فقدت سياسه المقردين في
التعامل مع مواجهه الدول الفقيره لازمه
المناخ دعت اسكتلندا الى زياده التركيز
على الصله بين تغير المناخ ومستويات
الديون خوف من عدم ضخ اموال كافيه الى
البلدان الناميه لمساعدتها على مقاومه
اثار الاحتباس الحراري
وبسبب ارتفاع درجات الحراره وندره المياه
وزياده ملوحه مياه الرائحه حذر المعهد
الدولي لبحوث السياسات الغذائيه في مصر من
انخفاض المحاصيل الزراعيه الغذائيه في مصر
باكثر من 10% بحلول عام 20 50
[موسيقى]
الخامس